of all the chicanery and shenanigans
that democrats pulled during the 2020
election perhaps the most brazen and
significant was big tech's decision to
censor the hunter biden laptop story the
censorship was outrageous and dangerous
in and of itself a group of billionaire
oligarchs deciding what could and could
not be presented in the public square
before an election
but now the story has gotten even worse
thanks to mark zuckerberg's revelation
on the joe rogan podcast
that he and facebook and big tech only
censored the story
because the fbi told him to
basically the background here is the fbi
i think basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um
just so you know like you should be on
high alert there was
we we thought there was a lot of russian
propaganda in the 2016 election we have
it on notice that basically there's
about to be some kind of dump of of um
uh
that's similar to that so just be
vigilant so our protocol is different
from twitter's what twitter did is they
said you can't share this at all um we
didn't do that the distribution on
facebook was decreased but people were
still allowed to share it so you could
still share it you could still consume
it when i say the distribution has
decreased it got shared how does that
work it basically the ranking and news
feed was a little bit less
so
fewer people saw it than would have
otherwise so it definitely by what
percentage i i don't know off the top my
head but it's it's it's meaningful but
we weren't sort of as black and white
about it as twitter we just kind of
thought hey look if if the fbi which i
still
view as a legitimate institution in this
country it's a very professional law
enforcement they come to us and tell us
that we need to be on guard about
something then i want to take that
seriously
so facebook censored the story but
actually only a little bit but actually
pretty significantly but actually mark
zuckerberg doesn't remember how much and
it did so because the fbi told it to a
little tough
to follow the contradictions and the
equivocations but at the very least
zuckerberg is telling us that the fbi
the allegedly non-partisan federal law
enforcement agency that had been
illegally attacking donald trump since
before he even became president
interfered in the 2020 election to keep
damaging information about the biden
family out of the public square
information so damaging that 17 percent
of biden voters in swing states
according to one survey said that they
would not have voted for biden had they
known about the laptop before the
election
would have swung the election to trump
the deep state pressured big tech
to help elect democrats and kick a
republican president out of the white
house but remember
if you question our oligarchs you're a
threat to democracy i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from dollyshortcake
who says i'm really pissed about this i
paid all my loans off for my bachelor's
degree and we now have to pay for
deadbeats who don't want to work or got
a stupid degree i've had it with this
administration just terrible
i think that's resonating for a lot of
people
i think just as the the libs think that
current hispanics who either were born
in this country or legally immigrated to
this country that they're really in
favor of illegal immigration and it
turns out they're not you can you can
just see it poll after poll
hispanics immigrants and the descendants
of immigrants who are here in this
country actually
hate illegal immigration well it's the
same thing here they think that college
graduates are going to love this
giveaway of the the free student loan
forgiveness
in fact i think a lot of people who took
out student loans and paid them off are
going to be much more resentful actually
than just the the regular old taxpayer
who's going to have to fund this because
they're going to say i did the right
thing why are people who were perhaps
irresponsible or who were just friends
with democrats or who got majored in
something that wasn't going to pay off
later on why are they getting a free
ride when i did the right thing
the democrats
not just the democrats
the libs
because we're not just talking about the
political party we're talking about the
whole kind of liberal establishment
especially in the bureaucracy but
through all the rest of society too
the libs
reward their enemies reward their allies
and punish their enemies that's how they
do politics
and it is pretty much politics 101 it is
pretty much the most basic way of
thinking about politics going all the
way back not just to ancient greece but
going back to the days of the cavemen
you reward your friends and you punish
your enemies that's how they do this
the way they do this is
before the election the fbi comes
knocking on facebook they say hey listen
here listen listen my boss is over there
in washington dc they sure would
appreciate it if look there's going to
be some information about hunter biden
coming out you understand we don't want
that to come out you understand what i'm
saying
that would be very unfortunate if that
came out so we're gonna just
we're gonna sweep that one under the rug
right right there's a nice tech company
you got here sure would be a shame if
something happened to it okay we're good
we're good okay good
that's what they do and what does
facebook do first of all facebook is
just full of libs and it's part of the
liberal establishment anyway so they're
probably more than happy to oblige but
even if they weren't they're feeling the
force of the government the permanent
government the administrative
bureaucracy the deep state and they're
saying okay i don't want to get on the
wrong side of the fbi don't forget what
chuck schumer said
he was in a way making fun of donald
trump but in a way he was giving a
warning to everybody in a way i think it
was quite sincere when he said don't go
against the intelligence community
they'll kill you nine ways from sunday
they could destroy your life so easily
just don't do it
and that's what happened here
that's what happened that's that's the
same sort of thing you're seeing on the
student debt forgiveness there's not
much of a principle at play here it's
just a political payoff the democrats
are paying off their friends
and
that they're doing that in a very direct
way and then in a less direct way
they're punishing their enemies
the people who
who don't go to college who are less
likely to vote for democrats the people
who are financially responsible and paid
off their student loans who are less
likely to vote for democrats those guys
are going to now have to foot the bill
for the people who are getting the free
ride
even among the staffers of the white
house
realtor politics uh philip wegman just
reported that
one in five white house staffers
currently has student debt
at least 30 senior white house officials
have outstanding student loan balances
this is according to financial
disclosures representing one in five of
the staffers who are required to file
the documents
and so
biden's giving a handout to his friends
and he's punishing his enemies and
maybe republicans should learn a little
lesson from that
you know republicans
they're so eager to prove
that that they're really neutral and
they're really high-minded and they're
really above politics
the conservatives are so eager to do
that that's what the never trump
movement was the never trump movement
was listen i don't i don't support all
this tribalism i don't support these
party politics i mean this is you always
hear
the squishes in almost every election
you'll have some moderate republican who
comes out and says ah look i'm a
republican but i'm going to break with
my party country before party which is
an it a meaningless statement you join a
party because you think it'll help your
country you think it's the best thing
for your country so country before
parties is a
distinction without a difference but
they do it because what they're really
saying is look i'm not
i'm not just going to help my friends
and punish my enemies no no i'm above it
all i'm at frankly i'm fairer to my
enemies than to my friends that's how
high-minded it is and that's how you
lose that's how you lose at politics
that's how the libs take over the whole
culture for the past 60 years
maybe conservatives should learn a
little bit of a lesson from the lips we
shouldn't do things that are unjust we
shouldn't do things that are immoral
which the libs often do
but i think we can engage in regular
normal politics where you have alliances
and you help out your constituents and
you don't just constantly cave in to
your opponents the libs are not messing
around
have you ever heard of swatting
swatting not like when you swat a fly
swatting like when you call a police
department and you make a false claim
about a violent incident at the home of
one of your opponents or enemies in the
hopes that they will send a a swat team
there with guns drawn
to
bust down the door and who knows what
happens at that point you ever heard of
that marjorie taylor green has heard of
that because the libs have swatted her
now twice
and this is not just marge retailer
green claiming this this has been
confirmed by the police
marjorie taylor green
wakes up in the middle of the night
because the the police are there
with a you know a major show of force
because they get a call that there's you
know a violent incident who knows what
the call contained
this has happened to my friend tim poole
tim pool has been swatted now multiple
times
swatting is attempted murder
guys i don't think i'm being hyperbolic
here you are calling this in you're
saying there are there are guns being
fired there is a major violent incident
so that the cops bust in the door in the
middle of the night
and start shooting
because what happens if i wake up in the
middle of the night someone busts down
my door
maybe i reach for my gun maybe i assume
naturally that i'm there's a home
invader there maybe then you get into a
provocative situation with the police
the only reason to do it
is to kill your enemies
i don't see wilds if you just want if
you just want the doorbell to ring you
can order them a pizza
if you just if you want them to
just get in trouble i don't know you can
uh
i don't know what you could do
you could you could call in some lesser
crime you could say i i saw them
jaywalking you know and then they'll
send this but when you call in the swat
team you are calling in a hit squad to
kill your enemies
that's how the libs are playing here and
it's not just that they've done it to
mars retailer green it's not just
they've done it to tim pool they've done
it to a number of people
you don't hear the same thing happening
on the right
furthermore we're now seeing federal law
enforcement being used as a tool of the
left you're seeing with the fbi
censoring the hunter biden laptop story
you're seeing it with the fbi busting
down the doors at mar-a-lago
i think we got to get a little bit more
serious about our politics here
certainly swatting should be
classified as attempted murder and
prosecuted as attempted murder and
whoever does it should be thrown in the
can for life
but i think we've got to we've got to
wake up a little bit
and see the way our politics is actually
working and the the
right wingers the squishes who insist
that we just need to uphold the norms
and traditions of the value-neutral
public square with all the institutions
that are apolitical and all that doesn't
exist and that hasn't existed for many
years
and burying our heads in the sand and
really wishing that we could go back to
a time in the past which probably never
existed in the first place
when politics wasn't really politics
that's not going to help anything
at all
we've got to get together we've got to
talk really really clearly when you want
to speak clearly to your friends you got
to check out puretalk right now head on
over to puretalk.com use promo code
knowles podcast thanks to bite inflation
you are paying way more than you should
for gas and groceries polls show that 94
of americans are upset or concerned
about the impact of rising prices and 95
believe that soaring inflation is very
or somewhat serious obviously it is as a
result every business is trying to
nickel and dime you not just inflation
but shrink inflation they're trying to
figure out how little a product they can
give you for the same price or a higher
price
one thing you don't need to be worried
about is spending more money on your
phone bill pure talk gives you talk text
and plenty of data for just thirty
dollars per month no price increase
there it's actually probably two-thirds
cheaper than what you're currently
paying i am a pure taught customer they
are incredibly reliable
i love it i travel a ton as you all know
for work the 5g coverage is phenomenal
by switching to puretalk the average
family of four is saving 75
every month customers are realizing that
they don't need as much data as they
thought that they did and when you make
the switch from your current provider
it'll take you 10 minutes it's super
quick puretalk is offering their best
discount ever to our listeners one month
for free lock in talk text and data on
america's most reliable 5g network for
just 30 bucks a month plus get one month
free when you make the switch today go
to puretalk.com enter promo code knowles
podcast for this special offer that's
puretalk.com
code knowles podcast
speaking of murderers
john fetterman the socialist democrat
candidate for senate from pennsylvania
is is really awful he's just really
everything about him is just
bad
and pretty much every he's probably one
of the worst candidates out there right
now that the libs are running and
somehow he keeps getting worse john
fetterman was asked if there were one
thing that he could change in society
what would it be his answer
he would let murderers out of prison
if you had a magic wand and you could
wave it and fix one thing
what would it be
life without parole in pennsylvania we
could save billions in revenue long term
we could save thousands of lives and not
make anyone less safe and also expunge
as many permanent records of people that
have been living their best lives and
have been paying well beyond when they
should have for a charge that they
caught you know 10 15 20 years ago
what's the if you had a magic wand it's
not even if you had to deal in practical
politics if you had a magic wand what's
the one thing you would change about
society
would you
solve world hunger
no
would you cure
childhood leukemia i don't know would
you all the horrible diseases all the
good things that happened to bad people
no
you would let murderers out of prison
so says john fetterman
because he says look these guys who
committed murder some of them have been
in prison for 10 years already come on
that's wait that's way past the amount
of time that they've paid their debt to
society
this is as radical as it gets
i really really don't want that guy
to enter the united states senate
unfortunately the republican candidate
dr oz is not running a very good
campaign right now
hope they turn that around because this
guy
we talk about how aoc is so radical we
talk about how raphael warnock is so
radical they are they're pretty radical
compared to
i don't know even 10 years ago in
american politics
this guy makes those people look like
ronald reagan
he's got just kind of a weird look to
him you know he's just something weird
about the eyes
and he's never held a job in his life
and he's been on his parents
forget his parents cell phone plan he's
been getting 50 g's a year from them to
support his lifestyle and he's just
not good not good no bueno pretty weird
stuff speaking of terrible crimes
the children's national hospital in
washington dc
has just admitted to something that the
libs were telling us was a crazy
right-wing conspiracy theory and we're
learning this thanks to one of the great
journalistic outlets out there libs of
tick tock
for a while now
the conservatives have said
we've just been right about everything
we've said that if we allow weird sexual
revolution stuff pretty soon they're
going to be doing it on kids and the
libs said that's a slippery slope and we
said yeah maybe but you know that's
we're slipping down it so it's going to
happen obviously that did happen we were
told if we talk we said if we tolerate
the weird sex change gender surgery
stuff pretty soon they're going to be
doing it on kids we were told that's
crazy conspiracy theory turns out that
was true then it was reported just a
couple of weeks ago that there are
hospitals who are performing transgender
surgeries like surgically removing the
womb from little girls we were told
that's crazy it's a conspiracy theory
you're misinterpreting and it's not true
move along move along so libs of tick
tock
called up the children's national
hospital in washington dc and just asked
them they said hey do you perform
hysterectomies on 16 year old girls and
and even younger here's what they said
hi i was calling um because i'm looking
for information about the gender
affirming hysterectomies that you guys
offered
yes
um this is the clinic
did you want to make an appointment so
they would do it um for uh for that age
yes
okay great is it a common procedure that
you guys do for for that age
yes um we have um all different type of
age groups that
for the gender for the hysterectomy
yes now okay
just out of curiosity do you know like
what's the youngest age you would do it
on
i'm not sure but i have seen younger
kids and i'm not you know
i'm not allowed to say that but i have
some younger kids
younger than your child okay
the underaffirming hysterectomy surgery
yes okay
um okay i really appreciate your help
right from the horse's mouth and you
can't even say listening to that oh well
that reception is she didn't she didn't
understand the question she didn't know
the conversation was very very clear and
the receptionist even knew that she
wasn't supposed to say what she was
saying she was you know there's hipaa
laws and
you know i probably shouldn't be
admitting this but she thought she was
talking to a new customer so she was she
was trying to entice the customer to
come in the customer being a pervert
parent who was going to rip her kid's
womb out
and she says yeah no we've had we do
this we we rip out the wombs of 16 year
old girls to make them pretend that
they're boys and get them on a lifelong
regimen of expensive drugs and
mutilations yeah we do that actually we
do it for kids who are younger actually
we do it for kids who are a lot younger
yeah yeah that's what we do
all of which is to say
there is no argument for supporting the
libs in any way
there is no argument for voting for a
democrat there is no argument for never
trump there is no argument for
for rewarding your enemies and punishing
your friends and your allies there's no
argument for that if there ever was
that's gone now
no principled argument no dignified
david frenchie in response no liz cheney
and mitt romney well look i think
actually there's a lot we can work with
these democrats on there's not they're
ripping out the wombs of little young
teenage girls
there's not and they already were
supporting killing hundreds of thousands
of babies a year and they sick federal
law enforcement on you on your on your
enemies and anybody who squishes to
these people it let him be anathema
okay i don't know how else to put it
there's
we we're so past that
we're so past oh well you know look
reasonable people can disagree on
whether to rip the wombs out of little
girls they can't
they can't and the libs don't want to
reconcile the libs don't want to meet in
the middle the libs don't want to
concede anything they want to sick the
swat team and the fbi on you
and look hey man if you if you answer
that door at two in the morning with
your gun drawn if something bad happens
oh well it's too bad
at least then we can take your kids and
trans them
okay that'd be really important and then
we'll have more political power us libs
and then we can do the most important
thing if we had a magic wand in society
which would be to let all the murderers
out
do you think there's any
any meeting in the middle
with that kind of worldview
i don't
i don't think so at all they're not even
really making arguments for it by the
way they're not making arguments for any
of the things they're doing right now
they're they're not even making
arguments for the student debt relief
okay the kareem jean-pierre the white
house press secretary was just asked hey
i know that you're giving this handout
to your friends and i know you're
punishing your enemies but can you make
any even attempt at a facade of a
reasoned argument as to why this is a
good thing for society
here's your answer
the heroes act tangent is on
student debt cancellation being tied to
the pandemic and that being a national
emergency but the administration argued
in court that the pandemic is over at
the southern border
to lift title 42 it's so over that the
government's going to stop buying
vaccines in the fall and shift to the
private sector so how
is this a national emergency
how's cobra national emergency when it
comes to students so it's a very good
question and i'm glad you asked it um
look we use the heroes act uh because
there are going to be some be some
people when we lift the pause that's
still going to suffer they're still
going to have a little bit of a hard
time uh and so that's one of the reasons
uh that uh
we made this decision uh because as
we're lifting up the pause yes you know
some folks may the having not to pay for
two years has been helpful to them uh
and are we're able to save and we're
able are probably going to be able to to
pay those monthly payments but there's
going to be some folks who are going to
have a hard time
uh because um
because they're just in a different
bracket right it just because they it is
they've they've probably had a hard time
before okay did you catch that at the
end at the beginning she said we're
using this this act the heroes act which
says that in times of national emergency
and really wars the president can
forgive debts
and so we're using that now and we're
saying the emergency was covid
and and so then
this reporter says well hold on that's
one that doesn't really count and two
that's not happening right now and three
how did how did that emergency stop
these kids from being able to or these
adults now from paying back their
student debts
and what does karine john pierre say she
says oh no you're right it wasn't some
emergency it wasn't covet it wasn't any
of that yeah they're just in a lower
income bracket
right now or they're
they're not they don't have enough
wealth right now and yeah they were
actually probably having trouble long
before kovid
so it's not an emergency so it has
nothing to do with the heroes act so
there's no legal basis for this
whatsoever
but they're going to do it anyway
because they want to reward their
friends and punish their enemies
because they're going to engage in
politics 101 which the conservatives
refuse to do doesn't make a lot of sense
does it no sounds like in a in a world
with so many downsides we really need to
get upside right now download the free
upside app use code
tmks from cringing at the pump to
getting an eye-popping check at your
favorite restaurant inflation is hitting
us all where it hurts where it really
hurts that is why you've got to start
using upside upside is an incredible app
for anyone who buys gas or groceries or
dines out is that you yeah i think it's
all of us with every purchase you can
earn cash back thanks to upside it's
incredibly easy to use you get cash back
every time you fill up on gas even at
certain fast food restaurants and coffee
shops it is not too good to be true i
can assure you it really really works to
get started
download the free upside app use my
promo code tmks it's very easy to
remember the michael knowles show tmks
get five dollars or more cash back on
your first purchase of ten dollars or
more next claim an offer for whatever
you're buying on upside check in at the
business pay as usual with a credit or
debit card and get paid simple as that
in comparison to credit card rewards or
loyalty programs you can earn three
times more cash back with upside upside
users are earning more than a million
dollars every week it's probably why
upside has a 4.8 star rating on the app
store download the free upside app use
promo code tmks get five dollars or more
cash back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more five dollars or more
cash back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more using promo code tmks
speaking of the libs just whining and
crying and instituting their own tyranny
of will
there is an event called the podcast
movement i had vaguely heard of it but i
don't really know very much about it
it's some conference where
podcasters go and have booths and talk
to one another and since
we here at the daily wire are one of the
largest podcast companies in the world i
think we're number six or number five or
something like that
obviously we had a booth at this
at this event
and
what do you know
the founding editor-in-chief of the
daily wire first show on our network ben
shapiro
shows up to the podcast movement makes
sense one of the most prominent
podcasters in the world would show up to
the podcast movement at the daily wire
booth because the daily wire is one of
the biggest podcast companies this
this was a really big deal the podcast
movement tweeted out
their heartfelt apology for allowing one
of the most prominent podcasters in the
world to show up
take a listen
ben shapiro briefly visited the pm 22
expo though he was not registered or
expected we take full responsibility for
the harm done by his presence
so do i get to get a picture
all right
god bless you thank you we agreed to
sell the daily wire a first-time booth
based on the company's large presence in
podcasting the weight of that decision
is now painfully
[Music]
clear during event planning the
dangerous nature of the company's
messaging was overlooked
[Music]
those of you who called this
unacceptable are right podcast movement
has made mistakes the pain caused by
this one will always stick with us
[Music]
yeah thanks for everything you do thank
you so much i appreciate it i'm excited
[Music]
truly harrowing
it's amazing that those people survived
the podcast movement is is begging for
forgiveness they say those of you who
called it unacceptable are right in nine
wonderful years growing and celebrating
this medium we've made mistakes the pain
caused by this one will always stick
with us
please we take full responsibility
please if you have any questions we're
here to talk i have questions
and furthermore i do not accept
your apology
i don't think that these tweets cover
the irreparable harm done by ben's
appearance and i want monetary
reparations for that
that's what i want from the podcast
movement the irony of course here about
the podcast movement which is some
two-bit conference who knows i don't
even know where it is
of them attacking ben and the daily wire
is that we are the podcast movement
we are not you not some two-bit
conference us the guys who are actually
some of the biggest podcasters in the
world not just the daily wire i think
what are we number five or number six on
the charts but it's us it's rogan
obviously there's a few other groups
it's really not just us
but it's a handful of us
okay
we're the ones doing it and by the way
the big podcasters skewed
disproportionately to the right or at
least anti-leftist joe rogan's not on
the right but he's not a leftist that's
that's for sure
this company obviously skews to the
right
the reason for that is that the people
for years had been
prevented from accessing conservative
information because of the left-wing
gatekeepers in the institutions of the
media and then podcasting comes around
and podcasting is a pirate ship that's
what adam carolla calls it another guy
who skews at least a little bit to the
right who's not a leftist he was the
pioneer of podcasting
and the libs are furious about that they
hate that the conservatives are able to
get their message out there in a
relatively freer platform so they're
doing everything they can to shut it
down and they make themselves look
ridiculous because they're afraid of ben
shapiro who is a relatively moderate
center-right voice as mainstream as they
possibly come in america the least
intimidating person on earth who's just
a sort of very polite guy who is
standing around
generously giving up his time to take
photos and
say hey to people and leave
so
the way they make it sound it's as
though the guy showed up with an uzi or
something like that
but they can't make arguments speaking
of gathering people together
this is my favorite story of the week
shyla buff
has converted to catholicism
that alone i love sharla buff who's had
some problems who like a lot of actors
has been kind of eccentric and explored
lots of different things shyla buff has
converted to catholicism he was doing a
movie about padre pio who's a great
catholic saint
and
my favorite part is the reason why
shia labeouf
converted to catholicism the holy spirit
would probably be reason number one
reason number two
because of the traditional latin mass
latin mass affects me deeply
deeply and
because it feels like they're not
selling me a car
and when i go to some mass with the
guitars and stuff and i'm from you know
santa ines right so that's where i was
catechized and there's a lot of guitar
playing and there's a lot of like what
feels like
um
like they're trying to sell me on an
idea i was always an agnostic even when
i was a sam harris ted talk you know
christopher hitchens guy
which is who i was before i fell in um
um
it um i always had a belief but i never
had like a connection latin mass gave me
something where i felt connected uh
which took me out of belief into
connection belief kept me
you know i had belief because that's the
rational
logical
it's not logical or rational to be
atheist if you really go deep enough you
get to the big bang and then then you're
screwed again you know you have to
account for it somehow which puts you in
a belief situation right but
too much of that logic and that too much
of that rationale takes me out of
feeling which takes me out of connection
so he's describing it at the end in this
kind of actory way which is he this
immersive experience he's had at the
traditional latin mass but i i also love
that that line at the beginning i love
the latin mass i'm drawn to the latin
mass why is that because i feel like
they're not trying to sell me a car
it's so true the mass that existed for
most of the last 2000 years until 1970
when a bunch of boomer libs uh decided
to destroy the liturgy not just the
boomers it was even the generation
before
when that when that happened
and then they instituted all the weird
guitar churches and all that kind of
stuff uh it drove people away it drove
tens of thousands of priests away it
drove
countless laity away because they feel
like
all of a sudden they're just being sold
something you know the priest is no
longer facing the altar and we're all
facing it together but the priest is
facing you and he's doing a little soft
shoe and he's telling yucky yuck jokes
and it makes it all about you
but you go to church
to get out of everything being all about
you everything's all about you for your
whole week probably you go to church to
experiencing to experience something
different outside of yourself outside of
the world you go there for an experience
of heaven and that's what charlotte buff
is describing he says i'm i feel like
i'm let in on a secret like i'm part of
something like i'm really witnessing a
miracle take place
and it's not just a show
to to entertain me or to
please me i love it
probably it's the lib liberal kind of
church reformers who are going to be the
hardest hit because it turns out the
youths don't want squishiness and
electric guitars they want truth they
want orthodoxy they want smells and
bells and a glimpse of heaven that's
what they want i love it this is my this
is wonderful stuff welcome to the church
shia buff
is it ironic to make an ad for an
ad-free viewing experience maybe it is
that's exactly the type of experience
that you will get when you subscribe to
daily wire plus this is our growing hub
for all things daily wire where you will
find shows and podcasts like this one
and movies and bonus content and coming
soon kids content daily wire plus is
everything you love about the daily wire
plus so much more minus the ads go to
dailywireplus.com become a member today
get 35 off your new membership that's
dailywireplus.com
finally finally we get to my favorite
time of the week when i get to hear from
you in the mailbag our mailbag is
sponsored by puretalk go to puretalk.com
select a plan enter promo code knowles
podcast to get one month free without
further ado let's get to the voicemail
bag
good morning michael knowles
two questions for you
one quick and one a little less so first
does the daily wire have a tip hotline
for newsworthy tips
and second congratulations on your new
baby boy my wife and i just had our
first child a month ago or so question
is where do you go for your vaccine info
we have already been denied service at
pediatrician for not giving our newborn
the hep b shot i said she doesn't live
in a brothel which i'm sure didn't help
but who can you trust
i'm not anti-vaxxed but 72 shots before
our daughter is four seems ridiculous
does daily wire have a resource page we
can turn to
thank you so much for all you do and may
god bless you and your family
really great question i had the exact
same experience that you did i'm in the
hospital certainly with my first kid and
they tried it again with my second kid
they say okay we're gonna give your kid
a thousand shots i said ah i don't think
so i don't really know what shots are
you giving my kid
say oh well this then the other thing
and and we uh obviously we've got to
give your kid
the shot for hepatitis b i said hold up
why are you doing that do you think that
my kid is going to go shoot up heroin on
skid row do you think do you think my
kid is about to go find some hookers
you know before he nurses and and goes
into his bassinet why are you and they
had no answer other the closest thing to
an answer they had was well um
sometimes the husband cheats on the wife
you know and before birth and doesn't
tell her and then the wife gets
hepatitis b and she doesn't know it and
then passes it to the kid during birth
oh thank you
thank you that's really i i assure you
none of that happened so no you're not
going to give my kid that shot and
really what it is i think is the public
health people
knowing okay we've got these people here
we want to pump them full of everything
that we possibly can because on a macro
scale maybe that will slow down the
spread of certain viruses and also
because there's regulatory capture by
the big pharma agencies which want to
big pharma companies that want to sell
shots so okay because of all of that
we're going to pump your kid full of a
bunch of stuff you say you say the thing
that all the conservatives have to say
now which is look i'm not an anti-vaxxer
but don't you think it's kind of weird
that like the covet vaccines don't
really do the thing that we're supposed
to do and look i'm not an anti-vaxxer
but it is kind of weird how like there's
a vaccine court that you know gives out
a compensation for vaccine injuries that
was specially established by congress
and look i'm not an anti-vaxxer but
i'm open to certain vaccine shots but
no i'm fairly skeptical of them now
i'm fairly skeptical of them because i'm
fairly skeptical of the public health
establishment because they've just lied
to us for two and a half years and if
they lied to us about kovit and they
lied to us about the kovid shots and
they lied to us about the masks and they
what else have they lied to us about or
even if it hasn't been an intentional
lie what else have they gotten wrong
when i was a kid
i got my vaccines
most of them at least but
the numbers that that are being given to
little babies now are so so much higher
and i think are those really necessary
why would i engage in any medical
intervention
that is not necessary
especially if the potential benefit is
very small and there is risk to any
medical intervention
so i wouldn't feel bad about your
skepticism on a lot of vaccines
i don't have one resource page it's
mostly just my wife kind of googles
things
but you can you can look those things up
and and some sources are more credible
than others uh usually peer-reviewed
scientific studies are more credible
than others but you can find stuff all
over the place and i think you should
not be ashamed of your skepticism next
question
okay michael love the show um so
recently i've had the weirdest phenomena
which is that i will be walking my dog
and my baby and my baby son who is super
cute and um
people will comment on how cute the dog
is and like not even acknowledge my son
um and
it's just like a really weird thing and
i've noticed there are like two types of
people there are people who acknowledge
your dog and there are people who
acknowledge your human child
and this also kind of goes hand in hand
with me noticing recently that there are
a lot of people who are walking their
dogs in strollers like as though it's a
child that they're pushing around
just wonder if this is like a larger
trend or maybe just something in my area
i'm not sure thanks
it's a major trend dogs are the new kids
it's very sad
it should not be the case you should not
treat your dog as your kid you can love
your you should love your dog as your
dog i'm not saying you should be mean to
your dog or not get a dog or not have
affection for your dog no you love your
dog your dog in a way has a soul it's
not a rational soul like a human being
has but a dog has a soul proper to its
nature
but a dog is not a kid
and if you treat the dog as a kid you're
only going to end up unhappy
you should if you can and so desire you
should have a kid if you can a lot of
people can't have kids and you really
want a kid you should consider adopting
a kid
and
if you
don't want any of those things but you
want a dog you can have a dog but treat
the dog like a dog
don't put the dog in a little stroller i
have friends of mine who do this it's
really really sad
you know something has gone wrong in
society
where we just we
coddle the little puppies and we we sort
of
stop on the street and say how cute that
little puppy is and then we ignore the
kids when we don't kill them
in the first place yeah something's
going really really wrong there treat
the dog like a dog treat the baby like a
baby next question
michael i think you know a question i'm
going to ask you because i bet you've
been bombarded with this question but
why did you have to bring the little
league into politics the way you did i
mean
when i was 12 years old if i hit
somebody in the head with a baseball i
would be traumatized i'd just be
thinking the worst i'd be terrified that
that kid was injured you have to go to
the hospital i mean you are shaking and
terrified you're a kid and for another
kid to come up the team like from the
other team to come up and maybe give me
a hug or let me know is okay
as a kid
where you're immature and you're still
learning about life
i'm down for it
i just want to know do you
want to take back anything you said
about that incident
or do you stand by everything you said
even though i know that what you said
the principle about you know being tough
applies to politics for sure just want
to give you an opportunity to either
defend yourself or to
explain yourself a little bit more i'm
very curious all right thanks have a
good one
i stand by everything i said
i haven't been bombarded on that for
those who missed it a week or two ago on
the show i played this clip that had
gone viral of the little league world
series and the pitcher kid beamed the
batter in the head and the kid went down
but he was okay you know knocked his
helmet a little but it still bounced off
the helmet and then the kid takes his
first base and then the first baseman
walks over to the pitcher and gives him
a hug
and i said man i bet these are such good
kids they're such good kids
they it's wonderful that's a great act
of friendship to do that i hope these
kids go out and get an ice cream cone
after the game but
the game is not the place for that
there's a time for every purpose under
heaven a time for war a time for peace
a time to embrace the time to refrain
from embracing and the game is not the
place for that and so you're making the
point yeah sure we got to be tough in
politics but we shouldn't come on we
shouldn't be tough on the little league
field no that actually that's the point
of little league that's the point of
introducing kids to sports that's the
point of education is to model the right
behavior for them and teach them
the appropriate times for behavior
and so yeah if the if the pitcher had
knocked the kid down and he were taken
out on a stretcher maybe that's a
different circumstance but he knocked
the kid down kid got right up dusted
himself off took first base
the pitcher was still a little shaken up
about it okay
but you you've the the purpose of these
sports is to is to
teach kids how to work through these
kinds of things and how to maintain
their composure
and how to
follow the rules and how to play the
game
and how to be competitive when you're
supposed to be competitive
and how to be sportsmanly when
when the game is over
and the the problem here is not that the
kid who got beamed with the baseball was
nice to the other kid the problem was
the timing there's a time and a place
for everything that was not the place
for it so no
standby i wouldn't punish the kids for
it
you know
you might say oh that was very nice of
you johnny but it's actually not the
place for that
place for that is at the ice cream
parlor or the soda fountain after the
game next question
hey michael i'm a big fan of the show
and everything going on at daily wire
i watched your interview with yurum
hazoni and the book conservatism a
rediscovery i decided to pick it up and
read it and thought it was really
insightful but i was wondering where you
fall on the dichotomy that he set up
between the hyper-rationalist view from
the enlightenment and what you're um
posited as the more conservative
historical empiricist view
and i'd never really heard of historical
empiricism so that's kind of why i'm
asking you about this do you think that
our ability to reason and know all these
universal truths
is all that we need i think our liberal
elites would agree with that but i think
maybe even a lot of people on the right
might before hearing about historical
empiricism or would you agree with yorum
that the conservative perspective is
more based on tradition and knowledge
that's inherited through the aegis
love to hear your thoughts on this
thanks michael i'd love to get to meet
you one day you inspire me a lot
oh thank you very much it's very kind uh
i think you can reconcile the two
with christianity i think christianity
uniquely reconciles the two in part
because
the divine logic of the universe jesus
christ the second person of the holy
trinity is incarnate and becomes man
and
the gospel is a journalistic account of
things that actually happened in time
and place
so right there you're reconciling
not just rationalism you're reconciling
reason himself
with historical empiricism uh but you
you refer to the enlightenment as this
kind of beginning of rationalism and
politics and that's
fair depending on how you you want to
use that word rationalism but yes the
enlightenment was wrong about pretty
much everything the enlightenment should
not be called the enlightenment it
didn't enlighten very much
the enlightenment if anything represents
a move away from christian civilization
but to try to preserve the good stuff
from christian civilization by while
taking god out of it and the early
enlightenment thinkers were not so overt
in their atheism and secularism but the
logical conclusion of the systems that
they devised i think is atheism and
secularism uh now there is a
pre-enlightenment kind of rationalism
when you think of the scholastics in the
middle ages you think of saint thomas
aquinas would be a great example of that
thomas aquinas is right again about
pretty much everything
but that's different because that's a
rationalism
that is centered around god
much different than a rationalism
centered around a vacuum in which god
should be
so yeah if you're going to try to reason
from a world without god
you're going to go off the deep end if
you reason from a world with god and the
natural law
then you're you're going to be a little
bit better off and all of that is
conditioned with a little bit of
epistemological humility with a little
bit of a kind of recognition that we're
not going to recreate the world anew
through our own unfettered reason that
our brains are not just the the simplest
way to do this but actually there is a
wisdom of the ages that inherited wisdom
prejudice and the in the really
proper meaning of that term is good and
we should defer a little bit to the
wisdom of the ages and tradition and
have a stable good flourishing society
where the best stuff has survived
those i think are very easily reconciled
but the kind of
rationalism of a world without god
uh that that's going to drive you off a
deep end uh all right before we get to
the member block i do want to get to one
question that was written in the regular
old mail bag not just the voicemail bag
this question from rich michael
you discuss and call out rhinos
frequently is there such a thing as a
dino thanks rich
no
no there's no no such thing as a dino um
the uh the the reason there's no such
thing as a dyno is there's the reason
there are rhinos is because there is an
incentive
for
the
squishy republicans to suck up to the
liberal establishment because they get
all sorts of goodies from it
so you get the republicans there but the
pressure of the media and academia and
the corporations and the bureaucracy and
all that pressure gets to them and then
they squish there's no similar incentive
or pressure on the
democrats to to move to the right
so there's really no such thing as a
dino you you get there's one or two
somewhat moderate democrats left in
america joe manchin and sort of kirsten
cinema
that's it though whereas on the right
you could name i mean we could be here
all day we could we could name hundreds
of them maybe we will in our member
block the rest of the show is continuing
now and you do not want to miss it if
you are not a member click the link in
the description and
join us
[Music]
[Music]
you